c'est la méthode d'interruption de
grossesse la plus utilisée aux
États-Unis 5 millions de femmes ont pris
la pilule abortive la mi fait pristone
prise avec le misoprostol depuis l'an
c'est 53% des Américains qui ont subi un
avortement mais il y a deux semaines un
juge fédéral du Texas à interdit la
méfaitstone car elle présenterait des
risques pour la santé des femmes
une décision qui soulève un tollé
oui
on ne veut pas qu'un juge ultra
conservateur d'une petite ville dit-elle
revienne en arrière sur des acquis oui
on ne veut pas de juge dans nos chambres
à coucher d'ici
d'autant plus que le médicament en
question a été approuvé par la FDA
l'agence qui régit les médicaments et
les éléments aux États-Unis il y a 23
ans will house
nous avons 20 ans de données qui
démontre que cette pilule est
sécuritaire dit-elle sans compter les
personnes qui l'utilisent en Europe on a
beaucoup d'essais cliniques sur ce
médicament
la cause est allée en appel en Louisiane
un panel de trois juges décide non pas
de l'interdire mais de restreindre
l'accès à cette pilule
dorénavant il ne faudra pas excéder
cette semaine de grossesse avant d'y
recourir au lieu de 10 la pilule ne sera
plus envoyée par la poste et les
patientes devront consulter un médecin à
trois reprises avant d'obtenir une
prescription
[Applaudissements]
à la Maison Blanche on s'insurge Joe
Biden réclame à la Cour suprême le
statut court
nous allons nous battre dit-elle on a
été claire là-dessus au même moment un
autre juge de l'État de Washington prend
les devants et autorise la mifapristone
dans 17 états démocrates
tout ceci discrédite la fditel c'est ce
médicament aujourd'hui demain ce sera un
autre
interdire l'accès à médicament autorisé
par la FDA crée un dangereux précédent
n'importe quel médicament développé avec
des cellules souches dit-elle pourrait
être contestée maintenant par les
groupes conservateurs
pour le moment la Cour suprême maintient
le statu quo soupir de soulagement donc
chez les gros projets jusqu'à la
prochaine bataille judiciaire ici
Radio-Canada Washington